[MUSIC PLAYING]
AGV: Let's say you
or your company
built an application
a while back,
and now you would
like to bring it up
to snuff and offer features
that modern apps have today.
For example, you
may want to enable
voice ordering or
mobile payments,
or you may want to make it
easy for other developers
to integrate into your app.
Or maybe you would like to
create a unified experience
across different lines of
business and multiple back end
services.
In this episode, I will cover
how Google's API management
tool, called Apigee,
helps organizations create
digital experiences
for both older back end
services, microservices, hybrid
or multi-cloud environments,
and fully serverless stacks.
API stands for Application
Programming Interface,
and it's like a library
of functions that passes
information over the web.
It defines the inputs and
outputs available over HTTP.
For example, let's say you
are a logistics company,
and you would like to
enable your partners
to integrate your
package tracking service
into their e-commerce website.
You then create an API
that takes shipment details
as inputs and returns a
tracking ID in the response.
Another API uses the
tracking ID to check
the status of the package.
This now makes your
service portable.
You can create services
not just for partners,
but for your customers,
employees, vendors, et cetera.
There are two
developer audiences
that most benefit from
an API management tool.
There are those that
build and manage
APIs, known as the producers,
and those that use the APIs,
a.k.a.
consumers.
Now, the challenge
to the producer
is to design an easy-to-use
API, keep developers abreast
of changes, and
ensure things do not
break as functionality evolves.
They also have to consider
three core design components
such as how will I prevent
unauthorized access
to keep things secure?
How compatible
will my services be
when working with other
platforms and devices?
And finally, how can
I measure that things
are running smoothly?
As you can quickly see, that's a
lot of layers to consider here.
Then there are
consumers of APIs who
need to easily discover
and find the APIs they need
and then quickly
understand how to use them.
And API is really only
useful if it can easily
be adopted by other developers.
So with these audiences
in mind, Apigee
helps manage the entire
lifecycle of an API.
Let me discuss
three key pillars.
The first is it
offers a supportive
portal for other developers
to discover your APIs,
rapidly understand
them with the intention
that they can build
applications with them.
The second is monitoring
and analytics.
These are available so
that your API program
managers can see which
APIs are used most and how.
You can also receive
alerts when appropriate.
The third is the
API runtime, which
executes the policies
you configure
for security, traffic
management, and efficiency
of your APIs.
What is especially nice is
that you can make changes
without disrupting
users because Apigee
is a proxy that isolates the
app developer from your back end
service.
For example, you can change
your database implementation,
move your services
to a new host,
or make any other changes to
the service implementation,
and by maintaining a
consistent front end API,
existing client
apps will continue
to work regardless of how
changes occur in the back end.
You also create one
or more API proxies
that map publicly available
URLs to your back end services.
A proxy is the HTTP
endpoint on Apigee
that developers use to access
your back end services.
You can optionally
apply policies
on a proxy to also add
functionality to a service
without having to make any
changes to the actual back end
service such as data
transformations, filtering,
conditional logic, custom
code, and many other actions.
The important thing
to remember is
that you implement
policies on Apigee, not
on your back end server.
Next, you bundle the API
proxies and publish them
in an API product.
Next, you let your
developers know that the API
product is available.
And once app developers
know about the availability
of your API product,
they can register
as an app developer
for your API product,
create an app to obtain an
API key for that API product,
and finally make requests
to your services,
passing the API key
with each request.
And there you have it.
A quick walkthrough
on how Apigee
helps create robust
digital experiences
by leveraging APIs
and having a tool
set and portal to manage them.
If you would like
to learn more, this
is only episode one of
a series of short videos
to help you get started.
Also, in this
video's description,
we have several helpful links.
And friends, if you found
this episode helpful,
you can click like or
subscribe to the channel.
Cheers.